it's more than 50 years since he boldly
went where no one had gone before that
of course was tv fiction now for real
william shatner will go where certainly
no 90 year old has ever been and you're
going to hear the engine cut off dressed
in the space suit of blue origin the act
has completed the final preparations for
a journey that will treat him to a few
minutes of weightlessness at the edge of
space and the realization of a life's
dream i'm thrilled
and and anxious and a little nervous and
uh a little uh uh
frightened about this whole new
adventure but i've got to think that
once it's done once i've been into space
and seen
the uh the universe and seeing our earth
and the contrast between that hostility
and this
warmth
and how important it is to keep
the earth alive so that we don't wreck
it
this time the man who as captain kirk
commanded the starship enterprise on our
tv and movie screens won't have to
control anything when the new shepherd
rocket blasts off from the texas desert
with him and three others aboard it will
be entirely remote controlled they'll
travel up 66 miles before gently
parachuting back down to earth the whole
thing will last 10 minutes
it's been made possible by blue origin
and amazon founder jeff bezos a huge
star trek fan he was the first to enjoy
the experience his billions paid for
back in july and invited shatner to
share it for free all's in our mission
he will be the oldest person ever in
space blue origin says he's met all of
the health and physical requirements to
make a trip to reach as captain kirk
used to say
that final frontier greg milam sky news
texas